[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم في دباسيلو
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور تاتينا من
البرازيليه حيث مازالت تعيش المدينه
والبرازيل برمتها على واقع ما شهدته من
احداث اقتحام قصر الرئاسه ومقار حكوميه
اما هذه الصور فمن العاصمه المكسيكيه التي
تشهد الان قمه ثلاثيه تجمع قاده المكسيك
والولايات المتحده وكندا وفي مواضيع
الحصاد هذه الليله
النيته والاتحاد الاوروبي يعلنان اتفاقا
جديدا للشراكه روسيا على راسي قائمه
التهديدات والصين تشكل تحديا وتوافق على
دعم اوكرانيا وزيره خارجيه المانيا في
خارف واشنطن تتحدث عن تغيير جوهر في نوعيه
مساعدتها العسكريه وتقول انها ستدرب
عسكريين اوكرانيين على اراضيها لاستخدام
منظومه
طرفا في السراء
وعلى الارض بعد حديثك يافا عن تقدم الروسي
الجزئي في المدينه وتاكيد استمرار السيطره
الاوكرانيه القوات المواليه لروسيا في
دنيا
على وسط مدينه سوليدار الاستراتيجيه وفي
حديث عن تصعيد مستوى المعارك شويكو يقول
ان القوات بلاده ستزيد من استخدام الطيران
الحربي ويجدد الحديث عن تطوير الرد النووي
تونس جدلوا السياسه والحريات منسق هيئه
القضاه المعزولين يمثل امام القضاء
للتحقيق معه على خلفيه تصريحيه ونقيب
الصحافيين يتهم السلطات بتحويل البلاد الى
ما سماها سجنا كبيرا للراعيه واستدعوات
جديده لانتخابات البرلمانيه ورئاسيه مبكره
وفقا نظام جديد الرئيسي يؤكد المذيع قدما
في تنظيم الدوره الثانيه للانتخابات
البرلمانيه
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا خبر دخولي مساعدات انسانيه
امنيه الى محافظه ادلب السوريه بعد اقرار
تمديد اليه ادخال المساعدات المعتمده في
مجلس الامن امس وهو خبر ياتي بعد اعلان
منظمه منسقون الاستجابه ان عدد النازحين
واللاجئين السوريين ارتفع ليبلغ 15 مليون
في رقم هو الاعلى منذ عام 2011 والاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التاليه هل يعيد تنفيذ اليه
دخول المساعدات او يعد كافيا لسد حاجات
اللاجئين
والنازحين السوريين وقد جاءت النتيجه على
النحو الاتيه نحو التسعه في المئه قالوا
ان تنفيذ الاليه يعد كافيا في حين صوت نحو
91% بالقول انه غيره كافر هذا السؤال
سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا ويمكنكم دخول
صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر
على الشاشه لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه
يتجدد يوميا وان نتطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
في كوسوفو احياء الصلب والالبان المشتركه
مخاوف تفرضها حسابات السياسه
[موسيقى]
وقع رؤساء الاتحاد الاوروبي والامين العام
لحلف الناتو في بروكسل اعلانا مشتركا
لتعاون والتنسيق وهذا هو الاعلان الثالث
الذي يتم توقيعه عليه بين طرفين منذ عام
اجواء بروكسل البارده لم تمنع بدء العام
هنا مبكرا في النيتو اتفاق جديد بين اكبر
مؤسستين في اوروبا السياسيه والعسكريه لكن
تضعه سيكون اكبر على حدود الحلف الشرقيه
مع روسيا
احتلال اوكرانيا خلال ايام وتقسيمنا لكننا
خرجنا اكثر قوه واتحادا وفشل بروتين في
مسرعه
والتحكم في جيرانه ولذلك سنستمر في تقويه
شراكنا وزياده دعمنا الكيف الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي يشكل اغلب دول حلفنيته يرى
في الشراكه مكسبا يستفيد منه الطرفان خاصه
بعد الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
وثانيتهما اننا اقتربنا اكثر
كما ادت الى تقدم السويد وفي لندن بطلب
عضويه الحلف بالاضافه الى اعطاء مولدوفا
واخكرانيا صفه مرشح لعضويه الاتحاد
في تفاصيل الاتفاق التزام بدعم ما اسماء
الطرفان حق ثياب في الدفاع عن نفسها
وتقرير مصيرها كما جاء ذكر الصين كترفن
يمثل تحديا لمبادئ الشريكين في مواجهه
عالم يوراد تغييره حسب البيان تعاون
مستقبل كذلك يعطي الطرفين استقلاليه اكثر
في مواجهه مطالب اوروبيه متزايده بقرار
عسكري منفصل لمواجهه اي تهديد
ياتي الاتفاق قبل اسبوع من اجتماع رؤساء
اركان الحلف لاتخاد قرار بشان ارسال اسلحه
متطوره لاوكرانيا فهل تنجح الابتسامات
المتبادله في حسم امر طال الحديث بشانه
رسائل عده حملها لاتفاق بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي والنيتو لموسكو وجيرانها وفي
التفاصيل حديث حول مزيد من التعاون
والتشارك والتزام بدعم اوكرانيا في مواجهه
حرب تقترب من عامها الاول عبد الله الشامي
الجزيره بروكسيل
الاتفاق كما اثرنا تضمن الحديث عن مزيد من
الدعم لاوكرانيا وهو مستمر اوروبيا ففي
زياره مفاجاه وصلت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه ان لينا بيربوك الى مدينه خارف
بالقرب من خطوط القتال الاماميه وقالت
بيربك ان اثار الدمار الروسيه عميقه في كل
زاويه وشارع ووصفت المدينه برمز جنون
المطلق للحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا وعدد
الوزيره الالمانيه بتقديم مزيد من الاسلحه
لكيف بالاضافه الى ما سمتها عروضا ملموسه
لمساعدتها على الانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي
بالتزامني مع حديث الشراكه والدعم تشهد
الاروقه الدبلوماسيه خصوصا ضمن دول الناتو
محاولات لايجاد صيغه مقبوله لتقديم ضمانات
امنيه لكيف بصرف النظر عن السيناريوهات
التي ستخلص اليها حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
سبق ان قدم عدد من الدبلوماسيين والخبراء
العسكريين تقييمهم لما هو ممكن الامين
العام السابق للنيترو اندرس رسموسن اقترح
تسليحه اوكرانيا بشكل جيد وترتيبا شراكه
استراتيجيه على اساس دون ايضا مع الغرب
بما يسمح بنشر جنود في اوكرانيا اما قائد
القوات الامريكيه السابق في اوروبا
الجنرال بن هودز فيرى ان الضمانات
الامريكيه لن تكون كافيه دون عضويه كامله
لاوكرانيا ضمن الناتو وتزويدها باسلحه
بعيده المدى لرد روسيا اما سفير الايطالي
السابق لدى الناتو ستيفانو ستيفاني فيرى
ان فكره قناه الامن كبيرهمتها قد عرف
عليها الزمن وان الحل يكمن فيما سماها
حلولا دبلوماسيه ابداعيه تضمن توفيره بعض
الاحتمالات القويه للسلام والامن
ينضم الينا من موسكو العقيد فيكتور ليتو
في كين محرر الشؤون العسكريه في وكاله تاس
الروسيه ومن بروكسل نيكولاس ويليامز
المسؤول السابق في حل في الناتو ابداء معك
سيد نيكولا السيد نيكولاس هذا الاتفاق
الثالث بين الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلفته كيف
يختلف عن الاتفاقين السابقين
يا برنس الفرق
واما جوهر الاتفاق فهو الى حد كبير كما
كان في الماضي التوقيت يختلف لانه ياتي في
خضم حرب تدور ورحها في اوكرانيا والغرض من
هذا الاجراء ارسال رساله الى روسيا بان
الغرب
وعلى وجه التحديد الاتحاد الاوروبي
ونيته لهما موقف واحد هذه هي الرساله
والرغبه في استمرار الدعم لاكرانيا
روسيا هذه الرساله
اسمي شناوي
الاتحاد الاوروبي هو الشيء واحد ليس هناك
اي فرق ان تركيا ليست عضو في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ولكنها عضو في الناتو فنلندا هي
عضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكنها ليست عضو
في ان ياتو الحد الان لذلك بالنسبه
لنا هذا الاتفاق المشترك شيء مضحك
ان هذا ممكن ان يقنع الجمهور الاوروبي
ولكن ليس السياسيين والمتخصصين الروس سيد
فيكتور ولكن هذا الاتفاق يقول السيد
نيكولاس يختلف عن الاتفاقات السابقه في
توقيته يا نص هذا الاتفاق على تعزيز
التعاون بين الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي
وتكثيف الدعم لاوكرانيا في حربها ضد روسيا
الحرب ليست حرب اوكرانيا ضد روسيا لانها
حرب الولايات المتحده ضد روسيا على حسب
الارواح الاوكرانيه وعلى الارض الاوكرانيه
وهذا شيء واضح القليلين الذين لا يرون هذا
لذلك الشراكه بينهم هو شيء موضحك انها
شراكه بين بروسيل وبروسيا نفسها لذلك
توتنبرجن لاين حسنا قاموا بتوقيع هذا
الاتفاق في الضوء الحرف في اوكرانيا ولكن
ماذا عن الحرف يغزلافيا وفي العراق حيث
شاركت هذه الدول وفي ضوء الحرب في ليبيا
حيث قامت بقصف دوله لها سياده او في ضوء
الحرف الافغانستان الم يكون لديهم هذه
الاتفاقات موجوده ايضا ليس هناك اي شيء
جديد انهم يخترعون
امور جديده
وتشكيلات جديده حتى يظهروا اهميتهم ولكن
ليس هناك اي اهميه في الموضوع انهم حلفاء
الولايات المتحده
من اهميه هذا الاتفاق ما الذي سيضيفه هذا
الاتفاق الى الدعم المقدم لاوكرانيا يتحدث
الاتفاق عن تعزيز الدعم لاوكرانيا كيف
ساجد
من قبل هذا الاتفاق هو استمرار ولكنه ايضا
تعميق وتكثيف للتعاون بين حلف النايته
والاتحاد الاوروبي الفكره هنا مفادها ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي ومن النواحي الاقتصاديه
والانتاجيه في ما يخص انتاج الاسلحه من
جهه وحلف النيته من حيث كونه تحالفا عبر
المحيط الاطلسي سوف يوفرني الدعم
والتشجيعه لاوكرانيا في هذه اللحظه
التاريخيه
الحرجه لانها فعلا كذلك نعم هي رساله الى
موسكو ولكنها رساله الى شعب اوكرانيا ايضا
مفادها ان لا تعمهم بشكل كامل يعني الرئيس
الاوكرانيه تحدث عن وضع صعب في دنيا اسك
على كل الاحوال سنعود الى ذلك شكرا لك
نيكولاس ويليامز المسؤول السابق في حلف
الناتو كنت معنا من البريكسل اشكر ايضا من
نطق العقيد فيكتوريتو محرر الشؤون
العسكريه في وكاله تاسس الروسيه واذاكر
بالخبر العاجل الذي ورد على شاشه الجزيره
الرئيس الاوكراني الوضع في دنياز صعب
ويتطلب مستوى جديد من المساعدات العسكريه
سنعود الى هذه المساعدات العسكريه على
الارض اعلنت سلطات ودنياسك المواجهه
لروسيا سيطره الكامله على وسط مدينه
سوليدار الاستراتيجيه في مقاطعه اندونيس
شرقي اوكرانيا واضافت ان قوات مجموعه بدات
عمليه تمشيط المدينه وكانت القوات الروسيه
قد اعلنت صادقا انها تحرز تقدم على محور
القتال هناك في حين وصفت اكياس التقدم
الروسيه بالجزئي مؤكده استمرار سيطرتها
على المدينه
ينضم الينا من الكرامتورس مراسل جزيره عمر
الحاج عمر الجانب الاوكراني ماذا يقول عن
السوليدار
نعم فداء قبل قليل كان هناك ايضا تصريح
لاننا مايلر نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
قالت فيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه في سوريا
في المدينه وقالت ايضا من الجيش الروسي
يواصل هجماته في المدينه بالرغم من
الخسائر الضخمه التي مني بها وماذا اليمنى
بها خلال هذه الايام الثلاثه التي شهدت
تطورا في سير العمليات القتاليه هناك اذا
هذا الرد الاول الاوكراني على المزاعم
الروسيه التي تحدث عن السيطره عن المدينه
ايضا في حديث سابق لها قالت ان القوات
الروسيه حققت نجاحا جزئيا في هذه العمليه
وهي تدعي انها تحقق نجاحات تكتيكيه كبيره
وانها تسيطر على المدينه على الاقل حتى
الان هذا هو التصريح الاوكراني او الروايه
الرسميه الاولى
حول ما يجد الان في هذه الساعات في
سوريدار كذلك الامر لابد من التفكير
بتصريحات الرئيس رزقي الذي يتحدث عن وضع
صعب في تلك المدينه فدان هنا من مكاننا
نبعد عن نحو من 30 او 35 دقيقه بالسياره
ولكن هناك تصاعد في اصوات الانفجارات
قادمه من بعيد هناك اصوات لايضا تحليق
الطيران الحربي الاوكراني فوق مدن اكرام
تورس والدروس كيف وهذا بطبيعه الحال
انعكاس ربما على هذه العمليه او هذه
المعارك التي تجري الان في سوريا اداره
التي لا يمكن الجانب الاوكراني ان هناك
صعوبه في التعامل معها وان كانت قد تحدثت
عن ارفاده مواقعي هناك بالقوه باللواء 46
محمود جوا والذي يعتبر نخبه المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين وبثت صورا من قتال هؤلاء
هؤلاء ولكن من صور داخل المدينه هذا يعني
بطبيعه الحال ان المدينه فعلا تخوض حرب
شوارع وان كان بالاوكراني لا يريد ان ياتي
على الذكر هذه الجزئيه بالتحديد عن ان
القوات الروسيه فعلا هي داخل همم المدينه
القوات الاوكرانيه اعترفت اكثر من في اكثر
من مناسبه ان الوضع صعب بالنسبه لها خاصه
وانها تتحدث عن احضار او استخدام قواتي
فاجنر لمئات والالاف من المقاتلين
المتمرنين بالقتال الى المدينه
العسكريه الضخمه ايضا اريد فقط ان يشير
الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه
كان كل منهما يتوعد الاخر بها جمال خلال
الايام القادمه مع وجودي موجه الصقيع الان
في من تقدم بس والتي خطت تلك الاراضي التي
كانت مليئه همم كانت هناك كان هناك نتيجه
الامطار الان الصقيع يعطي الافضليه
للعربات العسكريه همم الدبابات وهذا ربما
ما يفسر التغير الملحوظ جدا والمتصاعد في
سيره عمليات خاصه في سوريا دار شكرا لك
عمر الحاج مرا جزيره من كراماترس
على خط امدادن استراتيجي بين منطقه
سيدنيتسكو لوجانس في اقليم جمباز تقع
باخموث وتخوض القوه الروسيه هجمات لدخول
المدينه من ضحيتها الجنوبيه ومن المناطق
الشرقيه للمدينه الصناعيه ومن شان السيطره
عليها بنحوسيه منطلقا للتقدم نحو مدينتين
اكبر وهما اكرام تورس والسلوفيا المعركه
الاكبر تقع في بلده سوليدار غير بعيد عن
باخ موتور وتضع القوات الاوكرانيه في موضع
الحرج ذلك ان التلال المرتفع في سوليدار
تشرف على كل طرق الامداد وخطوط الاتصال
بما يتسهل وتطبيق موت من الشمال وتعطيل
خطوط التواصل الاوكرانيه وفق مسؤولين
اوكرانيين قصفه البلده ست و80 مره
بالمدفعيه في اربعين سنه وقال الرئيس
الاوكراني انه لا حوائط قائمه في سوليدار
وان الارض مغطاه بشده الروسي فيها وقد
تكمله اهميه المنطقه ووفاء
مجموعه في انفاق التعدين الغائره والممتده
تحت الارض والتي يمكنها ان تتسع للجنود او
الدبابات
انضم الينا من بيروت الاعمده الياس حنا
الخبير العسكريه والاستراتيجيه عميد الياس
تعليق على سيطره القوات الروسيه على وسط
سوليدار هل يعني ذلك بان المدينه باتت
ساقطه في يد الروس
في المبدا اييي فدى عسكريا قد تكون ساقطه
ولكن سقوط هذه المدينه وهي مدينه
صغيره نسبه للمدن الاخرى يجب اولا السيطره
الكامله التنظيف وتامين الامن العملاني
وهذا ما رايناه منذ فتره الامن العاملان
في مكيفكا تامين الامن العمليه ومن ثم
الاستعداد للانطلاق الى مرحله جديده وهذا
امر يتطلب وقت سوليدار مهمه بمقدار ما
تساعد على تطبيق مدينه محمود تحدث عن
بخموسه عميد الياس ابقى معنا نقلت شبكه سي
ان عن مسؤولين امريكيين كبار ان الولايات
المتحده غيرت بشكل جوهري نوعيه الاسلحه
المقدمه لاوكرانيا ما سيمنحها قدره اكبر
على الحسنه هذا هو اعلن البنتاجون ان
تدريب القوات الاوكرانيه على منظومه سيبدا
الاسبوع المقبل في قاعده فورت سيل بولايه
اوكلا هما الامريكيه حيث ستسلم منظومه
رياضي لكياف بعد انتهاء هذه التدريبات
الاوكرانيه على منظومه بتروت للدفاع الجوي
سيبدا الاسبوع المقبل في فورت سيلفي
اوكلاهوما التدريبات سوف تهيئ نحو 100
جنديين اوكراني على تشغيل المنظومه
الدفاعيه وصيانتها خلال مده تدريبيه من
المتوقع ان تستغرق عده اشهر وعند نشرها
سوف تسهم منظومه الدفاع الجوي لاوكرانيا
وتوفر قدره اضافيه للشعب الاوكراني ليتمكن
من الدفاع عن نفسه ضد العدوان الجوي
الروسي المتواصل
في هذه الاسماء اكد وزير الدفاع الروسيه
سوريه شويجو ان بلاده ستواصل وتطويره ما
وصفه بالثالوث النووي وستتحافظ على
جاهزيته القتاليه كضمان لسياده وسلامه
اراضيها
تتجه روسيا وزير الدفاع سيرجيو شويكو
يتعهد امام قيادات عسكريه كبيره ببناء
ترسانه اسلحه هجوميه احدث واقوى ورفع
كفاءه تكنولوجيا الطيران لتحسين قدرات
تفادي الدفاعات الجويه وتطوير انتاج
مسيرات تحدث وزير الدفاع الروسي عن الحاجه
لتقويه كل وسائل القتال وافرع الجيش
تقريبا مرورا بالافراد وشؤون الامداد
والاداره والاتصالات لكن لافته الابرز
كانت تركيزه على السلاح النووي
يشاء السلام عليكم
والحفاظ على استعداده القتالي لان الدرع
النووي كان الضمان الرئيسي لسياده دولتنا
وسلامه اراضيها
يقصد بالثالوث النووي ثلاث وسائل اطلاق
تملكها معظم القوى النوويه وحسب تقرير
امريكي فعناصر الثالوث النووي الروسي تشمل
القوه النوويه الجويه التي تملك منها
روسيا نحو 68 قاذفه ثقيله بعيده المدى
تتجاوز سرعه الصوت والقوه النوويه البحريه
فلدي روسيا 11 غواصه نوويه مصممه لاطلاق
الصواريخ البالستيه القابله لحمل رؤوس
النوويه والتي يمكن لبعضها توليد موجات
تسونامي اشعاعيه يفوق ارتفاعها 500 متر
الى جانب القوه النوويه الصاروخيه التي
يعتقد ان لدى روسيا منها 36 صواريخ عابره
للقارات يمكنها حمل نحو الفا ومئه 85 راسا
نوويا وبلوغ الاراضي الامريكيه سبق للرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين اواخر العام
المنصرم التعاهد برفع الاستعداد القتالي
للثالوث بلاده النووي مع اقتراب مرور عام
على بدء الحرب يتصاعد الحديث في روسيا اذا
عن رفع مستويات الكفاءه القتاليه فهل يرد
ذلك لتراجعات وازمات ميدانيه اوضحها عدم
الحسم رغم التفاوت الحاد لموازين القوى مع
اوكرانيا التي لا يدعمها حلفائها الا وفق
حسابات دقيقه او هكذا قضوا اغلب الشهور
الماضيه مؤشرات التراجع الميداني الروسي
تحدث عنها مسؤولون امريكيون واخراريون
قالوا ان نيران المدفعيه الروسيه انخفضت
عن اعلى مستوياتها في زمن الحرب بنسبه تصل
احيانا الى 75% معتبرين ذلك دليلا على
الضعف الروسي المتزايد في ساحه المعركه
لكن رغم ذلك لا تنظر واشنطن للمعركه باعت
فيها مشرفه على الانتهاء في القريب العاجل
بل هي تغير بشكل جوهري نوعيه الاسلحه
المقدمه لاوكرانيا والتي باتت هجوميه اكثر
من ذي قبل نقل هذا عن مسؤولين امريكيين
كبار قالوا ان الاسلحه المقدمه لاوكرانيا
ستمنحها قدره اكبر بكثير وان هذا جاء بعد
التزام كياب بالقيود المفروضه على استخدام
الاسلحه الغربيه ما خفف التحفظات بشان
ارسال انظمه اكثر تطورا هو اذا سباق روسي
غربي نحو القاء المزيد من الحطب في اتوني
حرب اوكرانيا يرافقه تعزيز روسي للقدرات
القتاليه النوويه وهي مؤشرات قد تنذر بامد
ليس بالقصير قد تستغرقه الحرب
عميد الياس هذا التغيير الجوهري في نوعيه
الاسلحه المقدمه لاوكرانيا كيف يمكن ان
يغير في موازين القوى على الارض خاصه انها
اسلحه هجوميه وانظمه صواريخ متقدمه بحسب
الجانب الامريكي
اولا اسلحه هجوميه البتريات هو دفاع
بامتياز لمنع السيطره الجويه الروسيه
اثنين
المدرعات التي قطعتها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه المانيا وحتى
بريطانيا مؤخرا هي مدرعات ليست الدبابات
بالمعنى الدبابات هي تعطي حركيه تعطي قدره
على المناوره وعلى قياده هجوم عكسي او ردي
على الاراضي الاوكرانيات من هذا المبدا قد
يكون هناك نعم مسؤولين امريكيين تحدثوا عن
اسلحه هجوميه تعطي للجانب الاوكراني
الاسلحه الهجوميه فداء داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ولا يمكن ان تخرج خارج الاراضي
الاوكرانيه على سبيل المثال الخطوط الحمر
الامريكيه هي عدم استعمال السلاح الغربي
لضرب الداخل الروسي من هنا كان قصف
القواعد العسكريه الروسيه بالداخل بمسيرات
سوفياتيه عدلها الاوكرانيون اليوم ما يعطى
للجيش الاوكراني هو الدفاع لاسترداد مزيد
من الارض مع حركيه مهمه وهو ليس الدفاع
بالمعنى الدفاع الداخلي هذا هذا هو
الروسيه وزير الدفاع يتحدث عن تطوير همم
التكنولوجيا التكنولوجيا الطيران المسير
ماذا يؤثر ذلك الى كيف يؤثر ذلك الى
المرحله المقبله
لا يمكن اليوم خلال المعارك ان يتم تطوير
هذه التكنولوجيا وادخالها في المعركه وهذا
الامر ما يفسره استيراد اكثر ما يقارب من
الف مسيره شاهد من عده انواع من ايران
بانتظار ان يكون هناك معمل تصنيع لشاهد
داخل الاراضي الروسيه اليوم عندما تبدا
المعارك لا يمكن اليوم تعديل اساسي في
التصنيع وحتى في القياده والعقيده
العسكريه وتدريب العسكر من جديد من هنا
دائما الحديث عن الموضوع النووي وكانه
الرادع الكبير لما يجري بقتال تقليدي على
ساحه الاوكرانيه شكرا لك عميد الياس حنان
الخبير العسكريه ولا استراتيجي كنت معنا
من بعيد
حديث الحرب في اوكرانيا والدعم الغربي لها
رافقه تصريح اخر الامين العام لحلف الناتو
عن مخزون الاسلحه الاوروبيه
واستنفاد خلال مرحله الدعم مفهومه مخزون
الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه سيكون محور نقاش ضمن
فقره في المتابعه بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
الى تونس وفصل جديد في ازمه
سلطه مع القضاء مع احاله منسقه هيئه
الدفاع عن القضاه المعزولين العياشي
الهمامي الى التحقيق على خلفيه تصريحا
اعلاميه الهمام اعتبر ان احالته للتحقيق
على خلفيه تصريحا اعلى ميجا تندرج في اطار
سياسه رئيس البلاد وحكمته في التعاطي مع
المختلفين معه في الراي اضافه لمحاوله
تغطيه عالم ملف القضاه المعزولين وفقا
تعبيره
الدفاع عن القضاه المعزولين العياش
الهمامي امام قد التحقيق الهمام كانت
تهامه وزيره العدل بعدم تنفيذ احكام
قضائيه عبر اعاده قضاه معفنين من مهامهم
الى وظائفهم وزير حقوق الانسان السابق اكد
انه لافقه بقضاء يسيطر عليه الرئيس سعيد
وان هذا التحقيق يندرج ضمن سياسه رئيس
البلاد في التعاطي مع المختلفين معه في
الراي
حقوقيوننا ومحامون تجمع في العاصمه تونس
تضامن مع الهمامي
54 الذي يتضمن تهمه المواجهه اليه
هو فصل جديد في مواجهه بين الرئاسه
والقضاء بدات تصاعد بعيده ايام قليله على
قرارات الرئيس سعيد الاستثنائيه في الخامس
والعشرين من يوليو 2021 حين وصف القضاء
بانه وظيفه في الدوله وليس سلطه مستقله
وفي التاسعه عشر من يناير 2022 اصدر
الرئيس قيس سعيد مرسوما يعدل القانون
الاساسي الخاصه بالمجلس الاعلى للقضاء
وينص على وضع حد للمنح والامتيازات
المخوله لاعضاء المجلس في مستهل فبراير
اعلن الرئيس سعيد حلا المجلس الاعلى
للقضاء واتهم اعضاء فيه بالفساد بعد ذلك
بنحو اسبوع وقع سعيد مرسوما باستحداث
المجلس الاعلى المؤقت للقضاء ومنحى نفسه
صلاحيه الطلب اعفاء كل قاضي يخل بواجباته
المهنيه في الاول من يونيو من العام
الماضي عزل سعيد 57 قاضيا من مهامهم
بيتهام بينها الفساد والتستر على متهمين
في قضايا ارهاب في ال 25 من يوليو وعتمد
دستور جديد للبلاد يمنح الرئيس صلاحيه
واسعه من بينها تسميه القضاه كما تخلو
مواد الدستور من اي اشاره الى استقلاليه
القضاء
هذا واتهم نقيب الصحفيين التونسيين محمد
المهدي الجلاصي السلطات بتحويل البلاد
تدريجيا الى سجن كبير للرئي على حديقه
اوله
المرسوم 54 اليوم تحول الى سيف بيدي صوره
كل الناس تخوف به كل الناس كل من يعبر على
الاراء المجتمع الكل اليوم في حاله سراح
مؤقت الى ان يعطون على 54 ويصد ما بين 5 2
و 10 سنين حبس تتحول البلاد الى
سجن للراي والسجن للافكار
ومحاكم تفتيش اللي صار معيش الهميم اليوم
محكمه التفتيش
محاكم التفتيش هي التي تفتش الاراء شفها
والمعتقده
والوصلتنا السلطه اليوم
هذا وداع حزب التيار الديمقراطي في تونس
الى انتخابات تشريعيه ورئاسيه مبكره وفقا
نظام الانتخابيه جديد يضمن لاستقرار
السياسيه في البلاد اما الرئيس التونسيه
وقيس سعيد فاكد ضروره استمراريه المرافق
العامه للدوله ودعا الى الاستعداد الكامل
لتنظيم الدوله الثانيه للانتخابات
البرلمانيه واخ خلال اجتماعه برئيسه
الحكومه نجلاء بودن ووزراء العدل
والداخليه والدفاع شدد سعيد على اهميه
توفير كل الامكانيات اللازمه للجنه
الوطنيه للصلح الجزائي المكلفه باسترجاع
الاموال من الموهوب
تنضم الينا من تونس شيماء عيسى القياديه
في جبهه الخلاص الوطني وينضم الينا من
تونس محمد ذويب الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
ابدا معك سيد شيماء سيد شيماء لماذا كل
هذا اللغد على التحقيق مع السيد الهمامي
والمرسوم 54 يضمن محاكمه عادله ايضا
الدستور في الفقره الثانيه على ما اعتقد
يضمن محاكمه عادله اذا لماذا الاعتراض
هذا ليس لغطا وليس اعتراض وانما رفضا
قطعيا لهذا المرسوم و رفضا قطع وجاهز من
كافتي يعني الطبقه السياسيه والطبق
الحقوقيه في تونس لهذا المرسول مرسوم 54
القاتل للحريه القاتل لحريه الراي لحريه
التعبير
شيماء
كل صوت مخالف لها السياسيين المعارفين
الحقوقين
وخاصه الشباب اليوم كانوا نشوفوا يعني
قديش من شاب وشيبه يحاكمون ويهرسلون وتاتي
الشرطه يعني لاخذه من منازلهم او من
المقاهي او مكان عملهم
ليعاقبوا على تدوينك يعاقبوا على رفده
عقبه على نقدهم لهذه السلطه يعاقب على
نقدهم لوزراء حكومه بدن اذن هذا المرسوم
هو قامع للحريه قامع للجمقراطيه اساسا وهو
اوجده قيس سعيد خصوصا نهائي
محمد
هل المعايير التي تفصل بين حريه التعبير
ونشر الاتهامات والادعاءات الكاذبه واضحه
في نظر السلطه التونسيه
وشكرا لك على الاستضافه من ناحيه الرد هذا
القانون 54 وق
د في علاقه
بما تتحدث عن الايقافات او ذلك لم ارى
ايقافات في تونس بطبيعه الحال الوضع
[موسيقى]
السياسيه تعقد ان ادوات السرعه عرضيهم
الاكثر وجودا في الاعلام تقريبا وتصنعون
حتى عوده الى احصائيات الاخيره هناك حراره
سياسي ادوات صحفيه وضع عادي لا ارى اي اي
شيء لهم الهماميه
العياش الهمامي اخطا عندما اخطا في
البدايه عندما دافع عن هؤلاء القضاه
الفاسدين والدعائن القضاء في تونس مستقل
مع ضروره تاكيد ان قيس سعيد لم ينجح لا هو
لوزارهته في اصلاح المنظومه القضائيه
بطبيعه الحال اذا ما قال الملفات يعني
عندما تقول انه اخطا في الدفاع عن هؤلاء
القضاه يعني بانه اليوم يحاسب نتيجه
الدفاع عن القضاه وليس لنشره همم اشاعات
كاذبه
السيد العاشر
خلفيه الدفاع عن هؤلاء القضاء ولكنه على
خلفيه تصريح اعلامي اتهم في رئيس
الجمهوريه ورئيسه الحكومه ووزيره العدل
بالفساد من حق وزيره العدل كم واقع العدل
هي تشتكي السيد العياشي الهمامي ومن حق
العياش الهامي لامي ان يتقاضى وان وان
ياتي للدفاع عن ذلك يكمل هائل من المحامين
الذين لم نراهم يدافعون على التونسيين
البسطاء العاديين الفقراء وابناء الاحياء
وغيرها بطبيعه الحال من حق العياشي
الهمامي ان يقع الطرف عنه هذا ما تم اما
الحديث عن خاصه وان السيد العريش الهمامي
ليس اسما كبيرا مع رفيقي سعيد تقريبا
اعتزل العامل السياسي او ابتعد عن عمليه
السياسيه باستخدام هؤلاء الذي يؤكد ان
القيامه
العياشي هو الوحيد الذي سيقى التحقيق معه
هنالك من سبقه عن كل الاحوال ساعود الى
اليك سيده شيماء اذا الحياه السياسيه تسير
بشكل عادي والمعارضون ينظمون احتجاجات
ويتحدثون في الاعلام لماذا تعتبرون بانه
هنالك خطرا على الديمقراطيه
اولا استاذ عايش يهمني قام نضاليه يعني
مشهود لها في كل البلاد ورده الفعل اليوم
الطبقه السياسيه والحقيقيه لمساندته اكبر
دليل على قيمته النضاليه العيش الهميمي
كان من اول الناس الذين فضحوا يعني
الاقليم وكان من مؤسسي مواطنون
اكبر دليل على انه متعطش لظلم الناس متعطش
الى فتح السجون لكافه يعني معارفي اليوم
الشباب اللي نحكي عليه وهذا موثق وموجود
في القصرين في في صندوبه في الجنوب في
تونس العاصمه امس فقط اتصل بمعنتها عائله
تقول ان ابنها يحاكم يحاكم على تدوينه
والمحامين يعني تستطيعوا ان تشوفوا
السيد محمد ان ليس الهمام هو الوحيد الذي
استدعي للقضاء هنالك من سبقه ومنهم علي
العريض وغيره من استدعوا الى القضاء هنالك
تظاهرات هنالك احتجاجات نقابيه هنالك
الاتحاد العام للشغل ينتقد ودعوات من اجل
الانتخابات مبكرا الى عند اتجاه الامور في
تونس وكيف يستقيم ذلك مع ما كان يتحدث عنه
السيد السعيد في بدايه عهدته
من الواضح انه ازمه سياسيه واقتصاديه
واجتماعيه في تونس هذا لا ينقله اي احد
هناك الرموز في المستقبل البلد الازمه
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه لسبابه لثلاثه
اسباب كبرى هي فشل الحكومه نجري مدان وضع
الوزارات
ها في الخلافات هذا اولا ثانيا الازمه
الاوك
رانيا وما بعد قرون واي
[موسيقى]
ضا خلقت البلاد وكملتها نتيجه السرقه
والنائب والنائب المال العام والفساد
وغيرها وافلاس المؤسسات العموميه بطبيعه
الحال الازمه في تونس موجوده الاتحاد
العالم التونسي الشغل المنظمه وطنيه كبيره
لا يمكن ان يزايد عليها احد ولكن ايضا على
الاتحاد العالمي حوار الا يكون على الحوار
على الحوار السابقه الذي حصل 2014
باريس وذلك التحالف بين حركه النهضه تونس
الذي ارسلنا الى ذلك
ان يقدم حوار ان يقدم الخطوط العربيه
الحواري من يحدد محمد شكرا لك محمد ذويب
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي كنت معنا من تونس
والشكر موصول لشيماء عيسى القياديه في
جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه
في السودان اصدرت المحكمه العليا حكما
بوقف قرار الرئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان تجميدا نشاط النقابات العماليه
التي انتخبت في عهد الرئيس المعزول عمر
البشير وعمرت المحكمه بوقف القرار الذي
اصدره البرهان في ديسمبر الماضي الى حين
الفصل القضائيا وبشكل النهائيا في القضيه
المرفوعه من اتحاد النقابات العمال ضد ذلك
القرار
في الاثناء وبين ما تواصل ورشه وتفكيك
نظام الثلاثين من يونيو اعمالها قال
المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه ان
النقاشات مع القوى الرافضه للاتفاق
الايطالي مستمره
السودانيين والتطلعاتهم الا عبر التخلص من
ارث النظام السابق الذي استمر ثلاثه عقود
يسمى ذلك في القاموس السياسي المتداول في
السودان اليوم تفكيك نظام الثلاثين من
يونيو او ازاله التمكين
تطلع بتلك المهمه ورشه عمل بثقه من
الاتفاق الايطاري الموقع في الخامس من
ديسمبر الماضي وتشارك فيها القوى الموقعه
على الاتفاق بنسبه 40% ومجموعات العمل
المتخصصه والخبراء ب 60%
الورشه انهت يوما ثانيا من عملها تخللته
جلسات شارك فيها خبراء دوليون وقانونيون
عرضوا تجارب عالميه في تفكيك الانظمه
الشموليه وقدموا مقترحات للجنه تفكيك نظام
عمر البشير
اعمال اليوم الثاني شهدت ايضا مداولات
ونقاشات ساخنه حيث طالب مشاركون بان تشمل
العمليه ما حدث بعد سيطره مجلس السياده
برئاسه عبد الفتاح البرهان في الخامس
والعشرين من اكتوبر عام 2021 وهو ما ادى
الى تعطيل عمليات التفكيك وبالتالي يتعين
على اللجنه الانطلاق من الصفر مجددا
بالتوازي تمضي قدما النقاشات مع القوه
الرافضه للاتفاق الايطالي سعيا لاقناعها
بالانضمام اليه وهي خطوه ستكون حاسمه
لتتويج المرحله النهائيه من العمليه
السياسيه في السودان وقد تعهد تحالف
الحريه والتغيير
باستقطاب بالغائبين والمتحفظين وبينهم
احزاب وحركات مسلحه قالت التحالف ان
حضورهم مهم جدا خلال الورشات المقبله التي
ستخصص للسلام والاصلاح العسكري والامني
وملف شرق السودان
[موسيقى]
الى البرازيل حيث تعاهد الرئيس لولا دا
سيلفا بملاحقتي من سماهم مموليد تحركات
الانقلابيه
1500 شخص على ذمه التحقيق في اقتحامات
مراكز السلطه في العاصمه البرازيليه وجاء
تصريحاته خلال الاجتماع
ورؤساء البلديات الكبرى في القصر الرئاسي
بالعاصمه البرازيليه وقد وافق مجلس الشيوخ
على قرار الرئيس التدخل الفيدرالي في حفظ
الامن في العاصمه
ينضم الينا من البرازيل يا مراسل الجزيره
حسان مسعود حسان اخر التطورات على
المستويين الميداني والسياسيه
مازالت العاصمه تشهد حركه امنيه كثيفه
لضبط الامن ومنع التكرار ما جرى في
العاصمه الاحد الماضي وذلك عبر تعزيز
الوجود الامني بكافه اشكاله من عناصر
واليات في العاصمه وما زالت هذه المنطقه
منطقه السلطات الثلاث مغلقه بالكامل لا
يسمح فيها بالدخول
المدنيين الى هذه المنطقه منعا لاي تكرار
للاحداث التي شهدتها العاصمه من اقتحام
مراكز السلطات الثلاثه اما ااه على
المستوى السياسي وكذلك همم فيما يتعلق
بالتحقيقات فان مجلس الشيوخ هذا الذي كان
قد تعرض للاقتحام شهد اليوم اول جلسه
حضوريه النواب واعضاء مجلس الشيوخ اقاموا
خلال هذه الجلسه بالتصديق على قرار الرئيس
البرازيلي بشكل رمزي ان هذا القرار يمكن
ان يمر حتى دون موافقه مجلس الشيوخ الا
انهم اكدوا على هذا القرار الرئاسي الذي
همم
يفيد بامكانيه التدخل فيدراليا وذلك من
قبل السلطات الفيدراليه بالامن المحلي
للعاصمه الفيدراليه ايضا لتعزيز الامن
ومنعي اي اجراءات بالاضافه ايضا الى
المساهمه الفيدراليه في التحقيقات مع
المشاركين همم
بالاقتحام اقتحام القصر الرئاسي والمحكمه
الفيدراليه وكذلك مجلس النواب والشيوخ
وياتي ذلك ايضا في اطار الاعلان عن اكتشاف
ان 10 ولايات ممولين من 10 ولايات شاركوا
في دعم همم ما حدث هنا في العاصمه
برازيليه وان التحقيقات تجري بشكل موسع
رئيس مجلس الشيوخ اكد كذلك على ان كل من
تورط وشارك سيقوم ستقوم اشرطه الفيدراليه
بملاحقته واعتقاله
كنت معنا من البرازيل يعني
يعقد زعماء الولايات المتحده وكندا
والمكسيك القمه العاشره لقاده امريكا
الشماليه في العاصمه المكسيكيه ويناقش
قاده البلدان الثلاثه توسيعه التعاون
الامني والتكامل الاقتصادي وملف الهجره
ومحاربه تجاره المخدرات بشان هذه القمه
تنضم الينا من مكسيكو سيتي مراسله الجزيره
وجد واقفي اهلا وجد واش سبق هذه القمه
اجتماعات ثنائيه ما الذي رشحها من معلومات
حول هذه الاجتماعات
نعم مرحبا فداء طبعا هذه القمه الثلاثيه
بدات خلال هذه الساعه على راس الساعه ومن
المقرر ان تستمر قرابه نحو ساعتين ومن ثم
يعقبها كلمات ختاميه للرؤساء الثلاثاء بعد
انتهاء هذه القمه طبعا سبق هذه القمه كما
ذكرت فداء لقاءان الاول عقد الرئيس
المكسيكيه لوبيز اوبرادور الليله الماضيه
خلال هذا اللقاء تناوله الرئيسان قضايا
وملفات شائكه مثل الهجره وتهريب المخدرات
والتعاون الاقتصادي والتغير المناخي همم
قضيه الهجره حقيقه قضيه شائكه جدا همم في
بين الولايات المتحده والمكسيك تدفق
اللاجئين بشكل ازمه بالنسبه للبلدين العام
الماضي نحن مليون
مهاجر غير نظامي
همم تسلل عبر الحدود
المكسيكيه الامريكيه تم اعتقالهم واعادتهم
الى المكسيك الولايات المتحده ايضا ليس
بعيدا عن الحدود ترغب من المكسيك ان تتخذ
اجراءات امنيه اكبر على صعيد مكافحه تهريب
المخدرات عبر الحدود الجنوبيه للولايات
المتحده مع المكسيك هذه تشكل ازمه بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده والاداره الامريكيه تتهم
المكسيك بعدم اتخاذ ما يكفي من الاجراءات
للمكافحه هذه القضيه بالمقابل الرئيس
المكسيكي تعمل رئيس ازدراء امريكا
اللاتينيه وعدم ايلائها اهميه خلال عهد
الرئاسي وهذا ما يحاول الرئيس بايدن اثبات
العكس تماما من خلال الوجود هنا في
المكسيك فيما يتعلق به اليوم اجتمع مع
الرئيس الوزراء الكندي جاستن رودو
الاجتماع ركز على التحول الى الطاقه
النظيفه وايضا على
التنسيق على صعيد الخطوات المتعلقه
بالهجره النظاميه وغير النظاميه الى
الولايات المتحده وكندا وهكذا تم تداول
السبل تعميق الاقتصادي ما تريده اداره
الرئيس بعيده من كندا هو ان تقدم معها
علاقات تجاريه تنافس العلاقات التجاريه ما
بين كندا وروسيا وهذا ما تحاول الاداره
فعله هنا خلال هذه القمه
[موسيقى]
اصدرت المحكمه العليا في مدينه جرينتس
النمساويه قرارا قضائيا جديدا يقضي باغلاق
ملف الاتحاد ضد البروفيسور المعروف فريد
حافظ استاذ العلوم السياسيه النمساويه
المصريه الاصليه
بالارهاب خلال حمله شهيره شهدتها البلاد
في نوفمبر عام 2020 واستند قرار محكمه
النمساويه الى وقائع ووثائق حصريه مسربه
عرضها تحقيق لبرنامج ما خفيه اعظم حمل
عنوان ليله الاقتحام وبثها على شاشه
الجزيره في شهر يناير من العام الماضي
وكشف بالادله اتهامات باطله وملفقه تجاه
الناشطين المسلمين في النمس
تعدوا مناطق شماليك كسوف القريبه من
الحدود مع صربيا بؤره للتوترات خلال
الازمات خصوصا في الاحياء التي يسكنها
الالبان من جحا وتلك التي يسكنها الصرب من
جهه اخرى لكن في حي البوشناق في مترو
فيتسا الذي يسكنه الالبان والصلب معا ورغم
ما يجسده من مظاهر السلام فان المواقف
السياسيه كثيرا ما تعكر صفوه هذا التعايش
حي البشناق في ميتروفيتسا شماليه كوسوفو
يكتب التجار على واجهات محلهم بلغتين
الالمانيه والصربيه بعضهم يختاروا
الانجليزيه وجميعهم يريدون زبائن من كلا
المجتمعين المحليين
سكنت عائلته هنا منذ اكثر من 100 عام كما
يقول ويملك هذا المقهى الصغير
وكل ما نريده هو السلام لا اكثر السياسيون
هم مشكله وسلكون في حال افضل لو تركتنا
الولايات المتحده والغرب وشاننا
على بعد امتار يدير نور الدين محل البسه
يؤكد الالباني الذي ولد في الحي احترامه
لجيرانه السرب لكن نظرته الى العالم
مختلفه عنهم الى حد من بعيد
التوترات الاخيره الى تراجع الحركه
التجاريه كثيره في هذا الشارع
بعنايه هيئات المحليه المتنافسنا يقول
الاهالي ان الاموال مخصصه للتسوق الى شراء
العقارات على حساب صيانه البنا التحتيه
صحيح انهم في عين عاصفه التوترات لكنهم
معفون من دفع الضرائب وفواتير الطاقه
مقابل بقائهم الحي صغير
بالضعه الاف ولكن من خلاله يمكن رؤيته
كتفه بمخاوفها واعمالها معا فهنا قد يتجسد
التعايش والقبول ومن هنا قد تشتعل
العداوات العرقيه مجددا محمد المدهون
الجزيره من بلده ميتروفيتسا شماليه كوسوفو
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى ما فرضته الحدث اوكرانيا على
مخزونات الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه للدول مخزون
الحرب لاحتياطي او ما يعرف اختصارا
بالانجليزيه دبليو ار اس هو عباره عن
مجموعه من مواد القتال التي يتم الاحتفاظ
بها جاهزه للاستخدام في مخزن ليتم
استعمالها اذا لزم الامر في زمن الحربه
وقد تكون موجوده بشكل استراتيجيا اعتمادا
على المكان الذي يعتقد انه سيكون ساحه حرب
وستكون هناك حاجه لامداد المنطقه بالسلاح
بشكل عاجل بالاضافه الى المعدات العسكريه
قد يحتوي مخزون الحرب لاحتياطي على مواد
خام لانها قد تصبح شحيحه خلال زمن الحربه
لذلك وفقا لهذا التعريف يمكن اعتبار
الاشكال التخزين كاحتياطيه البترول
الاستراتيجي مخزونا احت للحربه مثلا تعمل
وزاره الدفاع في الولايات المتحده على
تامين مخزون الحد الاحتياطي في جميع انحاء
العالم وبالاساس في بلدان حلف شمال
الاطلسي وفي بلدان بعض الحلفاء الرئيسيين
من خارج الناتو كما تحتفظ الولايات
المتحده بجزء من مخزونها الاستراتيجي في
اسرائيل اما بالنسبه للمملكه المتحده فقد
افاد مكتب التدقيق الوطني عام 2012 ان
التكلفه الثانويه للحفاظ على مخزون على
مخزون احتياط الحرب باكمله في البلاد كانت
200 و 77 مليون جنيه استرليني في حال
استخدام المخزون الاستراتيجي تعود الدول
ذلك بتعزيز عمليه الانفاق والتصنيع وتحتل
في هذه الحاله البنايات المتحده صداره
الترتيب العالمي اذا انفقت اكثر
نتريليونايت دولار عامه 2001 2021 للمره
الاولى وفقه معهد ستوكهولم الدولي لابحاث
السلامه وقال المعهد الدولي ان الانفاق
العالمي ارتفع بنسبه صفر وسبعه اعشار في
المئه عام 2021 ليصل الى ترليون
913 مليار دولار اما الصين سين فقط زاد
انفقها العسكري لمده 27 عاما متتاليه وفي
2021 خصصت بيجين نحو
2003 مليار دولار لجيشها وانفقت بريطانيا
اكثر من
86 مليار دولار على الجيش خلال 2020
بزياده ثلاثه في المئه وهي تحتل المركز
الرابع في قائمه الخمسه الكبار هذا ما
انفقته بريطانيا اما روسيا فقدت من
ميزانيتها العسكريه في الفتره التي سب
الحرب على اوكرانيا وقد بلغت اثنين
وتسعه اعشار في المئه بنحو 66 مليار دولار
حول هذا الموضوع ينضموا الينا من جناب
العقيد الكسند
فوترافيل رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه
السويسريه عقيد الكسند ماذا يعني نفاد
المخزون الاستراتيجي بالنسبه للدول واليوم
تحدث عنه الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي
انا
بالضروره عن الذخيره من حيث الاساس هنا
اود ان اؤكد على اهميه عدم اغفال عامل
المهمه بدات في الخمسينيات بوضعي اعراف او
تقاليد تقول بان اي بلدان في العالم يمكن
ان تنتج ذخائر وغيرها يجب ان تكون بتاخذ
بعين الاعتبار معايير
الناتو فلا يكفي ان نحسب ما لدى الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا من خزين لكن يجب ان
ناخذ بان الاعتبار ما تستطيع بقيه بلدان
العالم الاخرى ان تنتجه من هذه الاخيره
عن الدول الاوروبيه ايضا بانها استنفدت
المخزون هل يشكل ذلك خطوره مخزون
الاحتياطي بالا هبطتها هل يشكل ذلك اي خطر
على هذه الدول كيف يمكن تعويض هذا المخزون
الاحتياطي
يتم التعويض عنه من خلال مشتريات من
الخارج على سبيل المثال عندما تعطي
البلدان الاوروبيه الاسلحه والذخائر التي
كانت مخزونه عندها على ماذا 20 او 30 عاما
ربما وتبدا بشراء وطلب معدات وذخيره جيده
لقواتها طيب متى تلجا الدول عاده الى
المخزون الاستراتيجي وهل يمكن ان تلجا
اليه لدعم دوله اخرى
الميت
لحلف الناتو بلدانه
بان القوات
الاوكرانيه كانت بحاجه الى ذلك لم يكن لم
يكن هناك اي اعتبار اخر كان اعتبارا
سياسيا
المخزون كيف يمكن ان يؤثر على الانفاق
العسكري في الدول التي لم يعد لديها اسلحه
في مخزونها الاستراتي
خطوره واعتقد ان هذه الخطوره يتم معالجته
اثاره من خلال
روسيا لان روسيا في رايي كثير من بلدان
الناصر هي العدو رقم واحد والتهديد رقم
واحد لهذا السبب فان احتياطيات روسيا ايضا
تنظم في هذه النقطه علينا ايضا ان نؤكد ان
الكثير من بلدان النيترو تمر بمرحله تغيير
وانتقال الى انظمه سياحيه جديده وذخائر
جديده
لهذا السبب يبقى الامر مهمه سواء كان مهما
للاحتفاظ بالالافه القذائف ربما التي تلقى
بشكل عشوائي وربما ينبغي استبدالها بانواع
موجهه بشكل دقيق
يعني الدول بعد خروجه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من افغانستان كانت تتحدث عن جيش
اوروبيا له استقلاليه الى حد ما نفاد
المخزون مخزون الاحتياط لدى هذه الدول كيف
يمكن ان ينعكس على تجهيز هذا الجيش
المستقبلي
لا نتحدث عن الخيال العلمي لانني لست
الخبيرا في الخيال العلمي قضيه بناء
اوروبا وجيش موحد كان السلسله من
الاخفاقات
لتتوصل الى سياسه دفاعيه مشتركه اليوم
الدفاع الرئيس
اوروبا هو حلف النيته وليست سيد علي